sí snips y 1 pediste una vez más gracias
por vernos y disfruten de este episodio
de espectro me considero de la vieja
escuela todo estaba bien hasta que lo
arruinamos así que eso es importante
para ti y ser la cabeza de familia
soy el cuidador de la sociedad
jubilee presenta espectro invitamos a
seis hombres para ver sus opiniones
creencias y valores
[Música]
me he preocupado por el tamaño de mi
pene
[Risas]
de acuerdo 52 por ciento de acuerdo 48
es normal preocuparse por eso saben
cuando estás creciendo que uno se
pregunte si es normal saben
odio esto y me preguntaba esto será
normal o no pero con el tiempo me dije
no estoy bien creo que esta conversación
hace que me dé cuenta de lo
impresionables que somos y como nuestra
vida y nuestra masculinidad es definida
desde que somos niños cuando todos dicen
tienes que tener un pene grande y cuando
lo ves porque cuando ves un pene en las
porno si es como de 35 centímetros y
estás como el mío no se ve así entonces
te nacen las dudas de si tú tenemos un
problema de sonido tuvimos que repetir
todo y les dimos la oportunidad a los
invitados de cambiar sus respuestas
de hecho yo cambiaré mi respuesta
bien
[Risas]
cambie de opinión porque lo que él dijo
tuvo mucho sentido recuerdo la primera
vez que vi porno y de un pene de un
hombre de color me quedé como el mío no
es así con el tiempo fui mejorando mi
juego y no tuve más problemas no importa
el tamaño del pene es como dice no es el
tamaño del barco es cómo se mueve la
marea solo amas a una mujer se aman el
uno al otro y nunca volví a tener
problemas con las mujeres creo que para
los más jóvenes ahí es donde radica el
problema según lo que estoy entendiendo
tal vez si se hablará con más
naturalidad sobre el tamaño y eso con el
tiempo se normalizaría y estaría bien
discutirlo
creo que eso ayudaría mucho
un hombre debería pagar en la primera
cita 321 ya
[Risas]
encuesta de instagram y desacuerdo 52
por ciento de acuerdo 45 me considero de
la vieja escuela todo estaba bien hasta
que lo arruinamos así que eso es
importante para ti tomar ese papel de
liderazgo tradición de ser la cabeza de
familia
soy el cuidador de la sociedad ni
siquiera lo veo de ese modo una vez que
le das el poder a la mujer son ustedes
masculinizadas prefiero seguir lo que me
hace feliz mis abuelos mis padres yo
seguiré la tradición porque funciona
esta no es perfecta pero funciona
y ser un hombre eso es todo sabes no lo
sé creo que es territorio peligroso
cuando hablamos de ser caballeros al
final del día es como joya bebé si
quieres pagar aquí no hay jerarquía
entonces si quieres pagar está bien tal
vez la próxima vez le diré que yo lo
pagaré bueno es esta la primera cita si
la mera sólo tienen una oportunidad para
impresionar la que importa si es un
hombre o una mujer es el 2019 y tu
lógica no debería ser sin ofender como
mi abuelo lo hizo y le funcionó
funcionará para mí si ella no sale
conmigo una segunda vez solo porque yo
no pague a creo que me salve
apoyo al movimiento mito
321 ya
vamos sean honestos
en desacuerdo 11 por ciento de acuerdo
89 por ciento la primera vez que lo vi
hablaba con mis amigas familiares y
muchas mujeres del sur que decían estas
mujeres debieron hablar hace mucho
tiempo entonces tuve que tomar un tiempo
para procesar todo por mi cuenta y saben
que no estaban cómodas no estaban en una
sociedad o en un lugar donde fuera
aceptable que ellas dijeran algo y ahora
que tienen la plataforma y la capacidad
estoy como eso es genial di lo que
piensas que le dices a un niño que fue
acusado de violación cuya vida es
destrozada y las personas están como
bueno que siempre habrá personas que
quieran sacar provecho de eso no es algo
perfecto vamos mejorando con el tiempo y
creo que eso ha hecho más bien que mal
pero creo creo que hay que reconocer lo
malo
es por eso que estoy haciendo esto es
fácil decir y él me hizo esto y de
pronto esa persona es rechazada y
denigrada porque no hay oportunidad de
que él pueda llegar a decir algo los
juicios por turbas no son buenos la
mentalidad de los turbos es mala con ese
estoy de acuerdo pero no
solamente el movimiento michu pero es de
lo que estamos hablando ahora o esa
persona es mala entonces que se pudra no
hay un diálogo en todo esto y si es un
movimiento para expresarse está bien
esta jerarquía que hemos creado de
hombres y mujeres es el resultado de
cómo esperamos que actúen las mujeres y
los hombres si abrimos el debate a esos
temas todo cambia y yo estaré de acuerdo
con todo la masculinidad tóxica es una
exageración 321 ya
aún exagerada espera que algo
exagerada que como así pueden usar otra
palabra en desacuerdo 48% de acuerdos y
maravillas por ciento sí creo que estoy
un poco de acuerdo que es una
exageración porque creo que las redes
sociales un grupo de personas creó el
término y ahora todos somos juzgados así
creo que seguimos en un mundo que
todavía tiene la cultura de la violación
sabes las mujeres son acosadas a diario
y creo que todavía los hombres son
vistos o percibidos como tal vez una
presencia depredadora por las mujeres
así que es por eso que no creo que sea
una exageración creo que solo es algo
nuevo y si los hombres fuéramos buenos
no habrían feministas no nos atacarían
no nos odiarán hay muchos hombres que no
quieren casarse hay muchos hombres que
acosan eso así que si los hombres se han
vuelto tóxicos y una vez más tengo que
defender mis creencias sin mi moral
soy muy tradicional a entiendo lo que
dices pero la forma en la que lo dices
esta palabra morales como ya no sabes lo
que es la moral es que lo que dice suena
como si fuera el deber del
el guía moral de la sociedad no lo es
pero si los hombres quieren ser los
líderes los hombres deben diferenciar lo
bueno y lo malo que es es parte del
problema es por eso que creo que la
masculinidad tóxica pone demasiada
presión en los hombres y me parece obvio
que respondamos a la historia y al daño
que un mundo gobernado enteramente por
hombres nos puede hacer a nosotros es
por eso que creo que hablamos de la
masculinidad tóxica
me siento cómodo hablando de mis
sentimientos
321 ya
encuesta de instagram en desacuerdo 67
por ciento de acuerdo 33 por ciento toda
mi vida me inculcaron que mostrar mis
sentimientos era algo malo ni de mí
tratando de no
un ser gay así es como no yo no puedo
mostrar mis sentimientos porque no soy
gay no puedo ser gay no se supone que
sea gay así lo dice la iglesia a mis
padres mi mamá y todos me dicen que no
debo ser gay y darme cuenta de eso a los
25 ahora 26 me doy cuenta de que amazon
inseguro de acuerdo así es como se
siente estás triste así es como se
siente ahora me doy cuenta de esas cosas
pero mostrárselas a los demás en estos
momentos es muy difícil para mí yo
siento que soy muy expresivo sobre mis
sentimientos con mi esposa pero no estoy
totalmente de acuerdo porque no siento
lo mismo con nadie más es decir acabo de
reprobar una clase y por eso lloré con
mi esposa pero nadie más en la escuela
me vio llorar saben de hecho le escribí
a mi esposa acuesta a los niños antes de
que llegue a casa porque sabía que iba a
estar tan pronto como llegar a la casa y
no quería que vieran eso pero al día
siguiente me senté y hablé con ellos y
les dije quiero que sepan que papá no
pasó a su clase
y luego me dijeron de entiende las
verduras de frente a sus hijos recuerdo
que vi a mi papá llorar por primera vez
cuando su mamá murió y puedo recordar
que ver eso me marcó fue como wow
mi papá puede estar triste y creo que
ver eso fue algo importante
es una emoción real si es real fui
criado por dos padres que jamás en mi
vida vi llorar el efecto que eso tuvo en
mí fue cuando uno falleció de forma
repentina
yo no parecía estar afectado así que
tuve que hacer mucha terapia por eso de
este tema de la masculinidad de no poder
mostrar tus sentimientos es muy mala y
retrasa nuestros avances en la sociedad
y creo que tenemos que pensar en cómo
expresar nuestros sentimientos de forma
saludable juntos la gracias por
compartir gracias a ti por escuchar buen
trabajo y buen trabajo gracias igual tú
muy bien tengo que ser honesto yo fui
quien sugirió la pregunta del fin
y gracias y en por tu sugerencia
seguridad a todos los que también nos
escribieron sus sugerencias y nos
encanta este tipo de diálogos me encanta
porque como mujer me gusta saber lo que
ustedes vienen de me gusta suscríbase y
síganos en instagram instagram
e instagram nos vemos la próxima tapas
jubilee vive más